[Music]
it's good
it's only right killer
look
divided with Dave godpool is better it's
only right killer I'm a water handle my
ways before they wither away
me
a quarter Century or pain recruit all to
make the best in the game I keep sweet
vanilla suppose I'm the man of the game
before the issue a claim I'm a setting
it straight and it happened all in the
span of a day God will is better it's
only right killer
[Music]
[Applause]
but who is better
[Music]
suppose I'm the man of the game before
they issue
and it happened all in the span of a day
[Music]
the praise is
relationships rekindled
I'm still standing little accepting
Life's a big riddle extremely hectic
winner wiggle I deserve a soft shell
skill cultivate occupy the ground don't
fiddle I feel I hope a crystal I'm
thinking about the inmates suffering
from sickle you're still friendly
Stewart Little don't try people but way
back nipple subject Nicole
now I'm trying to generate generational
dribble Crystal
oh
[Music]
thank you guys